Hey look guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we finally actually used
shaders to draw a triangle properly and
that should work for everyone today
we're going to talk about something that
we haven't talked about thus far we kind
of just wanted to get everything up onto
the screen as quickly as possible just
having kind of raw OpenGL code right
inside our application class and today
we're finally getting to discussing kind
of the design the abstraction all these
kind of rendering API calls that we have
currently with OpenGL and how we're
actually gonna handle multiple rendering
API is because that's a pretty big issue
that really needs to be addressed when
you're thinking about your engine to the
line especially if you want to actually
have some kind of rendering engine that
supports multiple API so it's kind of
true big kind of abstractions that go on
in game engines usually to do with kind
of multiple platforms and that is the
multiple of actual platforms rights and
stuff like Windows Mac Linux Android iOS
ps4 Xbox switch whatever those kind of
abstractions were you actually doing
with different platforms and there's
also the rendering API abstraction in
which you're dealing with the potential
for rendering API is that it actually
maava basically supporting multiple
rendering API so being able to render
using DirectX using OpenGL using the
Vulcan any of that kind of stuff so both
are very big discussions obviously we're
talking about rendering API today and I
also want to kind of say that there's a
lot of schools of thought on this I've
seen in my professional career I've seen
a lot of different ways of doing this
the way that I like doing it and the way
that we're gonna do it for hazel is just
one of the many ways you don't like it
there's no correct way it depends on
what kind of suits your needs and what
you actually like and what you want the
API to look like and what you want the
code to look like programming and just
you know writing code is such a
subjective kind of thing I mean yes
there are objective truths as to sure
you could do it this way but it's like
technically on paper worse in every way
like sure the code might look pretty but
the performance is bad the abstraction
is bad the API is terrible well I guess
if the code is pretty the API wouldn't
be terrible but you get my drift I'm a
big believer of doing things like
properly in the sense of yes the code
might be harder to read and it might not
be as nice but it's gonna perform faster
obviously me coming from a background of
like game engine engineering at EA we
definitely care about performance
because we're trying to push the limits
so it's important to kind of consider
that and that's kind of just that's kind
of just who I am as a programmer I
really care about performance and I like
to kind of do it that way anyway I don't
wanna blab we're on forever I want to
give a huge thank you to all the patrons
that made this series possible Peter and
helpful stuff that sure know if you guys
sign up there you'll get videos early
you'll get access to these source code
to the hazel kind of development
repository the development branch which
I'm working on pretty much every day not
every day but almost every day last
video I actually showed like a bit of a
bit of a tour of what the hazel engine
actually is in the development branch
and that was like a huge kind of little
kind of show-and-tell that I did you
guys are more interested in that I
noticed that some people wanted me to
like make a video actually showing the
end like a standalone video just cannot
get tour of what we actually have in the
engine runtime and what everything what
it can actually do like all the features
if you guys interested in that
definitely leave a comment below but you
want access to that like right now you
can stamp on patreon football-sized sure
no help support the series and you'll
get access to that source code and to
that build ok so anyway back to this
let's talk about rendering API is how do
we support multiple rendering ideas so I
think the biggest choice that you have
to make here is if you're going to kind
of have this support during compilation
or during runtime so I kind of talked
about like what I mean by that
essentially what you could do right with
multiple rendering api's is you could
say that at compile time when I
physically compile my code right you
need to select a rendering API for
example I want DirectX and then what
will happen is you know viola
essentially if devs or certain files
that either compiled or not compiled
based on your kind of configuration
setup here you can basically choose that
like I am going to compile with DirectX
meaning that hazel is going to be built
with DirectX right if you want up in
jail then at compile time you choose
gl right and then all the files are
compiled uh kind of OpenGL specific
right and then you get opengl into your
final build and that and and to give you
a more practical example what I mean is
like you know you could have like
essentially a file for each kind of you
break down the rendering API into
primitives so you have like a vertex
buffer and index buffer texture class in
our shader class and then what you do is
you have like an OpenGL shader class and
then you have a DirectX shared a class
and only one of those will be compiled
right and the one that gets compiled
depends on your configuration setup
which depends on which rendering API
you've actually selected so you can kind
of do it like that right or you could
even just have a shade of file shader
for CBP and then just if def so the kind
of just says you know if DirectX is
defined then compile this chunk of code
otherwise if OpenGL is defined compile
this chunk of code right that's another
way to do it same same principle arise
just instead of breaking it up into
multiple files you have everything in
one file sure so let's talk about the
advantages and disadvantage of that okay
so the biggest disadvantage well some of
the disadvantages because I think that's
kind of the glaring obvious one is you
need a separate build of Hazel a
separate build a separate physical
binary build in order to actually select
which heavy I you want to use and once
you compile your code with that API
that's it you have to recompile the
whole engine or at least the rendering
component of the engine and like the
whole renderer if you actually want to
switch rendering APRs so picture this
right what I mean we're working and well
like I you know you will Rin this game
in like I don't know it's web console
sandbox project we've written in an
OpenGL suddenly I want to see what it
looks like in DirectX hold my beer while
I compile my entire code again with
DirectX
right that's not I'm not I'm really not
a big fan of that
so apart from development times being
kind of slow especially when you're
actually working on the renderer that's
another big thing but that people didn't
realize you have to make this developer
friendly so what I mean by that is while
you're actually developing the render
how you're gonna deal with this
well you know I've finished the OpenGL
implementation now I'm working on the
DirectX implementation I need to switch
between them right I need to switch
between between them to know whether or
not the visual parity is turn the same
right
I they're like scrapping
is between the two renderers does direct
axial difference to OpenGL it shouldn't
right it should be exactly the same if
it looks different I've made a mistake
so I'm gonna have to go back and forth
them quite a bit but to do that I need
to recompile my code and yeah I mean
there's a lot of things you could do
right OpenGL is done you could bring out
all the rendering code into a module so
it's like in a separate kind of
component in separate kind of module DLL
file whatever right and then if you want
to kind of just launch with OpenGL I
mean you could just or DirectX or
whichever one you're using you could
just you know switch which one which DLL
file it uses sure but that still means
that you need to recompile code and it
still means you need to do that kind of
at compile time right not something we
want to kind of do to do with that right
so that kind of decision is it falls
into kind of those two areas when do you
want to make that decision do you want
to choose which rendering API user
compile time or at runtime
obviously right now it seems like on x
definitely the superior one because what
you know why I have this hard decision
that you have to make ahead of time if
you can just make it at the very end and
still be fine with it right and what
kind of go on to that in a minute but
the other thing with this is that the
benefit the primary benefit of doing it
this way is essentially performance
right you you know which IP I you're
using you compile the hop the whole card
base with that API right which means
that there's no kind of runtime
decisions that ever get made not even
once that say all right well if we're
actually using this API want you to do
this no because all that stuff is done
offline all that stuff is done during
compile time and it means that during
runtime your code your your program your
engine doesn't have to make any
decisions and waste time that's what
waiting out waste time making those
decisions as to which API is currently
in you so which one you want to use
right that's not stuff that actually has
to be done because it's already been
done ahead of time at compile time so
once it gives you less flexibility it
does potentially give you more
performance now so about the second half
of things and that is making those
decisions at runtime so what does that
mean what that essentially means is that
you compile everything right
so you have an you have an OpenGL
implementation you have a DirectX
directx implementation both of those
implementations get compiled usually the
way you do this again you could just you
know instead of if deafs or whatever you
can't really do if Deaf's because you
can't have like a shader class that
suddenly does both I mean if you were
really crazy I'm like a big psychopath
you could probably just have like inside
of every kind of function that you have
right inside every kind of function that
you have for shaders like buying shader
or you know upload uniforms or whatever
you could have an if check that says hey
if it's DirectX run this code if it's
OpenGL run this code that's just like a
Pathak to be honest i don't know why
anyone would do that but i have seen
that that's why I'm mentioning it don't
do that you could do something like that
usually you break it up into multiple
files and potentially I can many ways to
do this but potentially if you doing in
a runtime you'd probably have a base
kind of abstract you know pure virtual
kind of class that has no
implementations probably stores no data
at all just act as like essentially a an
indirection and abstraction if you will
and then you have two classes or
basically one class that breaks off per
rendering API so you might have you know
a shader and you might have OpenGL
shader and you might have direct access
writer
those are both child classes subclasses
from that original base class which is
that just shader class right and then
since they're pure virtual the at
runtime when you actually create a
shader you decide upon creation right so
it's not really like taxing and there
are ways to make it even faster if you
want by like pulling your heads together
or doing whatever you want but
essentially when you create a shader it
checks to see what the current rendering
API you're using actually is and if it
is you know OpenGL then it creates a new
OpenGL shader and returns that if it's
DirectX it creates a new DirectX shader
and returns that right but the base type
it's returning is the base class type
which is a shader so you're all of your
client code that's in sandbox at this
stage right or inside your game that
just sees shader that's all it is it's
it's a pointer is some kind of reference
to a shader object but the
implementation detail of whether it's an
OpenGL shader would write a shed is kind
of hidden I mean usually you would
provide ways to extract that just in
case
because you know no engines API is that
that kind of complete really that you
can just do everything you want within
that it's a bit weird I haven't really
seen that before
I mean if you it depends what you're
doing if you're doing really simple
stuff you shouldn't need to dig in deep
into the implementation details but you
might so you might have that kind of
filtering through but essentially the
client code just says shader doesn't
care what shader is because if you think
about it what does it do it opens some
kind of you know credits a new shader
based on like a file or something it
binds the shader it uploads uniform data
it doesn't need to know if you're using
DirectX OpenGL because that's kind of
the API you've defined in that rendering
API kind of video thing that I made a
few weeks ago a few months ago maybe I
talked about that line right between
your actual renderer API and then your
actual renderer so the renderer just
uses the rendering API it doesn't it
shouldn't care which implementation
you're actually using which specific
render a you're using it should just be
as simple as just kind of just looking
up shader and being like I want to
create I'm gonna upload these uniforms I
want to bind the shader for rendering
right simple as that so obviously
there's the obvious fact here that if
like not all rendering ideas are
supported on all platforms so DirectX
we've been talking about directx and
opengl is our two main ones just for the
sake of this example right for the sake
of this kind of conversation OpenGL is
available in pretty much everything
DirectX is only available on Windows and
like Xbox and just Microsoft common
products so if you're compiling on Mac
or Linux your DirectX code is not going
to compile is it no it's not so you
still have to have like if devs
open or not even if that's the way I do
what I don't usually have with devs I
just have separate files so I have
shaded or H and maybe shaded or CDP
which is like my base abstraction and
then in my platform specific kind of
folder hierarchy
I have OpenGL shader dot CPP and our age
and then DirectX trader don't say VP
undulation right and director you don't
really need to worry about the header
file but DirectX shader dot CPP that is
turned off for like Mac and Linux bills
and probably all bulbs except for
except for windows at this right right
so that's not even gonna compile it's
only gonna compile when you generate the
project for Visual Studio for Windows
right if you're targeting windows that
gets compiled otherwise it does not get
compiled okay
and if I you don't need to worry about
that way obviously oh and then also
usually in your actual kind of generic
shader bill cpp you have like some kind
of create function which doesn't look
which does a runtime check and it says
which which rendering API are currently
using it's basically like a switch
statement if it's OpenGL do that
otherwise if it's DirectX and you have
that block inside if deafs then you can
return a new DirectX data so that way
it's kind of protective it's only going
to compile for Windows that's specific
code and I mean you know for other api's
it's kind of the same thing so you
wouldn't really compile metal on
anything except for Mac OS or iOS right
so you have that stuff either filtered
out by the configuration if they're
separate kind of CPP files or if depth
if they're in kind of common files
because you do need some kind of link to
a common file at some rate in this
anyway I've talked a lot
hopefully this design is making sense um
it's really cool to just sit down and
think about this I could draw a diagram
of all this I realized that I usually
don't because I I feel like it's not I
feel like it's just me running down my
words on paper I think for some people
it's good to see things visually so let
me know what you think about diagrams in
general I'll run a little poll maybe to
see if you guys want more diagrams I
mean I do them very rarely usually I do
them if the video is dedicated about
planning or something like that but the
main reason I don't is just because this
stuff is well it's in my mind it's kind
of simple to the like to the point where
everything I would draw is just the
words I'm saying so if you just think
about them and maybe rewatch that area
if you don't if it doesn't make sense to
you and just visualize it not to mention
where about it see the card behind this
so that will act as a visual aid
that's why I don't usually both of it
anyway I'm always open to feedback
obviously so please let me know what you
think we have several classes here we're
not gonna check to open today I think
what we're all we do the vertex buffer
because I think that's pretty easy just
to give you guys an idea and
what I want you to do for homework is
actually go ahead and do the same thing
with the shadow class do the same thing
with the vertex the right class do the
same thing with the index buffer
okay so in fact I think I will do both
the index buffer and the back spot for
today let's jump in and see what we can
do okay so this is where we left off
last time if we just run this then we'll
see what we get
so we had this kind of triangle that was
kind of interpolating between the vertex
position colors that we had here what we
did is we had just inside application we
had all this opengl code which obviously
is not something that we ever want to
keep right this is just kind of an
example of how to kind of get this stuff
on screen as soon as possible but what
we want to do now is make this generic
right make this generic in the sense
that you know I want to just be able to
like none of this other code has any
idea of what a rendering API is right it
doesn't really you know it's got layers
it's got event dispatcher it's got stuff
that is not render API specific instead
of creating stuff like this and having
GL code here that for example defines
our vertex buffer what I essentially
want to be able to do is create a vertex
buffer right which essentially you know
and the way you do this might be
different depending on how you choose to
implement it but you know probably want
to do something like vertex buffer
create we'll probably want to take in
you know the vertices like this maybe
the draw mode as well like the memory
storage type because is whether it's
static or dynamic or streaming or
anything like that
but essentially we want to probably take
in the whole kind of vertices definition
that we have here as a vet has buffer
and that's kind of it and then when it's
time to draw we just probably do
something like that X like buffer to
bind and that's done we want it to be
like this because we don't actually want
to include glad or anything like that
this could be using Direct X for all we
know and this kind of way of doing
things and obviously we don't just have
the open shell code inside vertex buffer
it returns an implementation of which
API we've actually chosen and will
actually create all of them right now
and see what that looks like okay cool
so that's kind of the goal usually you
do kind of usually this would returns on
sort of pointer I usually just like
returning a completely raw pointer in
here right and then it's gonna be up to
like if you do have an engine with a
reference counting or something like
that I would probably return a ref since
we don't have that at the moment I'm
just going to have create return a raw
pointer and then it's going to be the
clients job to actually manage that
however they like either by shoving that
raw pointer into like a shared pointer
or usually like what we're gonna do here
is just kind of putting it into a unique
pointer okay so let's take a look at how
we can do something like this this is
kind of the goal for the API so over
here in renderer I'm gonna make a new
item and I'm actually just gonna call
this buffer dot H now you might be like
well okay is this gonna be the vertex
buffer way clean your buffer there isn't
long a buffer is because I I'm not a
huge fan of creating a million files I
think that it's not that necessary I
think that it like it slows down your
build times it makes code harder to read
through if you want to like share your
code with someone you have to give them
a million files it's just a bit annoying
so I I definitely like creating more
than one file you can see I've actually
got quite a few here they might get
collapsed in the future or probably not
but for things like buffer I don't
really like having a vertex buffer and
index buffer kind of class they're both
buffers they're just different types of
buffers so you should just have them in
one of one file this is clearly just my
opinion feel free to disagree with it
but that's kind of what I do okay I like
to do something I basically like to
create code like this and then just have
multiple classes and want to file it
just makes it easier okay and then you
know I'll do the same for textures for
example so they'll just be one file per
rendering API called like texture
essentially and then in there we'll have
2d textures you know 3d textures cube
Maps that kind of stuff everything with
textures kind of all in one file instead
of having to have a separate a separate
file for each kind of type of texture
because that's just annoying in my
opinion anyway so we have both of these
will include alt PCH will include our
buffer class and then I'll had a file I
made and then
we'll have a namespace hazal
and then let's talk about what we need
here so this is our pure virtual
interface right what I mean by that is
there is no implementation here and
there is absolutely no members no data
members at all this this should take up
zero storage obviously it'll take up one
byte when we initialize it because it
has to its class but is Scot no members
it takes up no storage it's literally
just like a V table of just functions of
those virtual functions that get
dispatched to whatever kind of subclass
actually realizes this implementation
right this kind of abstraction so we
don't really need a constructor or
anything like that you do need to have a
virtual destructor usually this is just
empty right we'll do this straight away
I think for both of these so you kind of
get the idea of how it's implemented and
hopefully by implementing it twice as I
am here you'll kind of see what you need
to do to import the stuff of shader and
then we just define the interface so
vertex buffer what are the functions of
a vertex buffer well we definitely want
to have some sort of like binding
function so virtual void bind right we
want to be able to bind a vertex buffer
for rendering or if we want to put into
a vertex array the way that this will
actually work with the vertex array by
the way we will talk about that later
because that's a bit different and that
is actually a bit more API specific
unlike you know drug tests for example
which deals with this stuff differently
so bind unbind I definitely like to have
some kind of like set data upload data
things over for you know you if you you
would rather you do like virtual void
set data and then you have your stuff
here and now finally for the
construction what we actually want to do
is you'll notice is if I can find where
this stuff is we want to actually you'll
see that what we kind of want is the
actual vertex data right
that is attribute pointers as well
something to do with vertex arrays not
really something we want to do right now
but just this kind of chunk of code here
we need to actually give the vertices to
this
the wrong thing to this right however I
don't want to create a constructor
because if I create a constructor that
means that I need to actually I can't
kind of choose which type I want so what
I'm actually going to do is create a
static vertex buffer and again that's
what I said we're returning a roll
pointer it would be like maybe some kind
of ref if you had a reference counting
system inside your engine which we don't
at the moment
static vertex buffer create and makea
that's what this is like my constructor
so I taking everything I want here right
and it's static so doesn't actually
belong to this class and then I stuff
create and then I'll probably just take
in my vertices and then a UN 32t which
is my kind of size could just use a size
t by the way but we'll use you in 32 T
okay there we go done this is very
similar in both of these except this
returns a index buffer instead and we'll
probably have a UN 32 T which is our
industries right so we haven't unsigned
32-bit integer we're probably gonna kind
of stick with 32-bit integer 32-bit
indices for now 16-bit is definitely
optimization you could make in the
future but more often than not if you
turn around the things and you're trying
to just have a simple implementation
just you know a 32-bit is just the way
to go otherwise we'll just run out of
indices okay cool this looks pretty good
to me now which do you create these to
create functions so they're pretty easy
we just drag this over here this is
gonna be a better spot I'll create right
and then we do the same thing I'll just
use visual assist here to make this
implementation for me we've got this
here wonderful now what we need to do is
actually decide in this function in this
create function we decide which API
we're currently using
so what API are and Roy is using and
thus which which class type which actual
kind of class we instantiate and return
okay it's gonna kind of obviously cost
it through the base type here so we're
not returning the actual derived type
but that's that's the intention
cool okay so in order to have classes
returned away she needs to make them so
since we're kind of dealing with OpenGL
for now inside platform OpenGL I'm going
to add a new item and this is going to
be called OpenGL buffer dot H so you can
see that everything that is kind of
OpenGL related I'm starting with the
OpenGL kind of prefix here and then
buffer is kind of the fight the the type
of class or rather the file name over
the class inside the actual kind of
generic renderer
so we add this which is the rendering
API we have our namespace we include the
file from the generic kind of rendering
API which is this one right and then we
make our OpenGL vertex buffer class
which is a vertex buffer okay and then
what we do here is we actually implement
that file right so that class that we've
created this we we implemented here so
we don't need the create obviously so we
can take this we can put it in here we
can keep this as a virtual destructor
just because it's already virtual and
this way we know that it is special and
smart correctly and then bind it unbind
which by the way I should have made cons
and this stuff we just kind of implement
over here inside our inside our
implementation which is the OpenGL
Vettes buffer in this case you can put
anything else you want here right so
obviously we're going to put a renderer
ID did I'm a friend I don't
remember yeah I don't know I didn't it's
just a UN 32 usually I'd make a run dry
heat I have we'll talk about that in
another time in the shredder class we
just had a render idea so we store this
you'll note we store this in the actual
implementation we don't store anything
in here at all you shouldn't we
shouldn't store anything here right this
is just an interface just should not
sort any data this is where the data
where the data is actually stored so we
have a UN 32 team which is our n variety
we'll make an open GL buffer CPP file
open GL which will include our PCH and
what we can do here is just oh and one
thing that I definitely want to make is
a constructor which takes in exactly
what our create function takes in so
inside buffer we had this create
function which takes in vertices and
sighs that's what I want the constructor
to take in okay vertices and sighs now
let's create these implementations using
visual assist who by the way I'm not
sponsored by just I'm just like using it
and then over here we're gonna do some
things okay so first of all I mean look
this is a vertex buffer class this is
we're currently drawing a triangle in a
game engine new vertex buffer class is
quite exhaustive it's quite big
right there's a lot of decisions you
want to make such as whether or not you
retain this vertex information on the
CPU side which you might want to do if
you're doing things like ray picking or
you know ray casting to Mouse pick stuff
like that there's tons of different like
collision whatever there's tons of
different things you actually might want
to do from a vertex buffer what we'll do
for now is we'll probably won't retain
this we won't copy it and keep it here
but what we do need over here really I
think is well I don't know I mean we
don't really need anything to be honest
the size and all that stuff we'll handle
in the constructor so this is the actual
code we have here and what's clean Gen
buff is not great but that's ok we could
probably just
which to be honest if iti can use
something called to help create better
things buffers a job create buffers
right which is basically these two steps
in one so and I don't remember the
function see I think it's just that
we'll need a write-off for a song okay
so I don't know I'm just gonna look this
up so Craig buffers glad create buffers
there's a function signature okay cool
so it actually does just have the
buffers and a size okay so back here we
have our size then we have our render ID
all right cool we also need to include
glad age and there we go so we create
our buffer doesn't matter what kind of
buffer it is at this stage anyway when
we actually set up off a data bit that's
when we will use array buffer for vertex
buffer and element array buffer for
index bottom so we have we can't your
sides and vertices anymore obviously
it's just a pointer we sighs we use
vertices and we are now again hard
coding business static drop okay so
there we go and then we'll also have in
the destructor
which we haven't let's see so this needs
to not be implemented here anymore
we need to take this and implement it
here and then this will just GL delete
buffers because we don't want to retain
that gel bind buffer let's see so GL
array buffer and M R and writing and
then I'm buying which we probably will
not use that often but we will unbind it
then okay cool so there we go very
simple class just simply creates buffers
uploads them and then we can bind them
for rendering and I'll do all of that
kind of stuff okay so back inside our
application class let's try that out and
see what happens so we still have our
vertices we don't need to generate this
anymore if I go back to here we can
instead of having unsign in vertex
buffer we can get rid of that and
actually have a unique pointer to a
vertex pop-up and now that will be out
there Tex pop-up cool so then over here
um and I'll have to include this so
basically the same as that except the
vertex buffer so now over here we have a
vertex buffer I like to just use reset
so II's lost time yeah I did and then we
put this in here obviously we have the
dot offense in the size second here that
should be okay I get that Chloe didn't
work sorry it's not about it's my face
just buffer okay and there we go
and then that's kind of it I mean we
probably should bind it I'm actually not
sure if create create binds it or not
that's kind of the problem
mm-hmm I guess we can run this and see
what happens
but yeah that'll be interesting I don't
think we're doing anything you know
we're still doing buffer data so I
shouldn't shouldn't actually do that
let's just cancel that build I failed
anyway thank you I what it fail okay so
creative course Craig does nothing yet
we haven't sorted this out yet
so what you actually should do is we
don't have a renderer class which is
kind of annoying we should definitely
set that up next time because we really
need to because we also have kind of
generic renderer commands like clear and
clear color that you know in most cases
you could probably associate to a frame
buffer but also useful functions to have
inside your actual render as renderer
commands and inside that renderer class
we'd probably have a switch for the API
right so if you're using like OpenGL or
DirectX it would kind of the renderer is
what should kind of have that for you
right so what we'll do right now is will
create a renderer class which is just
called a renderer all right this is
gonna be so great for today but
basically what's what it's gonna do is
have an enum class render our API right
and then this is gonna be none which is
like if you're running headless or if
you just don't want to have it you may
be doing unit tests that
to require rendering I mean running them
on like a build a build machine or
something like that which might not even
have a graphics card in it you want to
test with so you have none and then you
have Arkin Jail and then in the future
you know we'll probably have like
direct3d or Vulcan or whatever but these
are kind of a - that we obviously have
right now okay this needs to be stored
in some kind of static state probably
again since I said it's gonna be really
brave essentially what we're gonna do is
just have a static renderer API it's
like the render class right which is the
s run variety I will just say okay and
then inside this video file which I'll
now have to create since I chose to do
it this way which is fine render SHP to
include our PCH will include our
renderer dot H name space hazel and then
this for now clearly something that we
can set at runtime but for now this just
gets set to render our API OpenGL okay
so without high creating it here
obviously it's something that you could
definitely set at runtime in fact we're
gonna add a get up for it so we'll have
inline public private
inline render API not in there get
render API probably just get API to be
honest clean side the renderer you could
call it current API or whatever and then
this will just Mississippi static and it
will just return ass right
yeah okay cool and then you could also
do set API but does the same thing if
you want to set this and obviously if
you set it before you create the
renderer and the context of the
application essentially before you
create the window and everything it
should use that chosen API
okay cool so now that we've got that
inside our open side adjust our buffer
class which is over here we will include
well already Inc yes we can just include
the renderer and then we do a switch
statement and we checked renderer and
get API okay so if it is non you know
then we'll probably won't return
anything so return a null pointer for
now we probably will have an
implementation that does nothing though
otherwise it'll crash so we could just
assert in this case to be honest and we
might do that edge set or assert false
and we'll say render API none is not
supported I'm currently not supported
and then we will return not pointer and
then for OpenGL boss
I know move this over here we will we
will return a new OpenGL vertex buffer
with the vertices and the size so I
really just kind of making sense how
this little works right
and then obviously over here we return
null pointer and we could just you know
also having a set here essentially that
says it fails that's if somehow you set
it to a value that's not here so just we
could just have a having a set as his
false on Aarn renderer api okay and then
i gel that his buffers before something
that we need to include so hazel
where is it actually platform its
platform not inside hazel apparently not
I can jump off oh right and then
obviously if for example right this will
shed some light here if for example we
you know had direct3d and direct3d
buffer a DirectX buffer or whatever you
called it right um that since that's
when there's only you would do something
like you know if H said platform windows
or something you would do this otherwise
you wouldn't right and that way you'd
still be able to compile this class on
like Mac OS and then same with this if
this was you know DirectX instead of
OpenGL you could surround this case
specifically by that right and then that
way obviously the direct tax code is
ignored and not compiled at all on
platforms that do not support it okay so
there we go
that is that and then that's pretty much
it
obviously for index buffer when you
should do the exact same thing so I'll
come over here our job offer is told of
the file here this will be opengl index
buff um which has our indices and our
size still not a class that we've
created yet i guess but yeah there we go
the exact same code right I just like to
tap his across cool so now I will have
to create that index buffer I guess so
if we copy and paste appears we'll call
this our index buffer and obviously it
will be an index buffer if we go to
buffing I was running out for some
reason but if we go here we can steal
this copy it paste it here it's gonna be
another long episode lucky you guys okay
index buffer looks good to me
and then if we go over here we can
basically copy and paste this I'm just
going to replace code here from vertex
to index all right and then obviously we
need to get the appropriate code
here which is that buffer Dada
this becomes elements alright well
probably might still need to bind it
we'll check that our in in a minute
we'll both learn that together I guess
indices and then I've been gelling this
buffer we change this to P element right
before everything else stays the same
okay cool and then usually what I like
to do is just kind of separate this
because it's all in one file and you
kind of want to see kind of the I guess
separation of these two things so you
know sometimes I do something like this
essentially and I don't know the
formatting for this varies I just kind
of change it up depending on my mood but
right now I guess I'll do something like
this which is just our index buffer and
then this will be our vertex buffer and
sometimes I do this in the header file
as well just so that it's super obvious
where we have those two kind of
implementations you probably don't need
to have like three full lines to take
yourself by the way in but do as you
wish
okay cool um so there we go we've got an
extra one here because I guess the
FairTax was too many lines or rather one
more character anyway so there we go
we're missing something cuz I put this
into the wrong spot lovely yeah that
looks pretty good to me if we go back to
the buffer save a file you can check the
make sure this all compiles and it does
and then back inside application instead
of having that index buffer as just two
unsigned in here will have an index
buffer instance yeah okay cool and then
for that to happen I need to include
buffer which I already am because
they're both in one file which is lovely
nice and easy we're going to do this
anymore instead of Gen buffers and all
that stuff and buffer data we can just
create the indices and then say M index
buffer dot reset index buffer create
indices science and that's all we need
and size is just size
and this is now actually this is a good
point right sir
the point is do we actually need size
here or should we rather have a count
the reason is that you are specifying
you and 32 indices they they you you
know the the size of them anyway so why
not just have a count and the other
thing that we actually do need an index
buffer which I have neglected is the
count right so virtual you and 30 to get
count and right and then this will just
tell us how many indices are actually
invisible next buffer which is important
for rendering since we want to commonly
render all of them so we'll have virtual
get count here which will return a count
and count and then you know GT and the
count right and then over here when we
take in the count
we'll set count so that we can do this
and then this becomes count times size
of you into a t-shirt okay so that's how
I like to differentiate between what is
in bytes and what is not advice right if
it's count then it's not invite us in
elements which means that you need to
multiply by the size if it's sizes and
bytes okay there we go
wonderful so now back in inside our
application we create this we create
these and we instead of having indices
in this case we just have rather size of
indices we just have three because
there's three indices in here yeah look
I mean if you wanted this to be
automated you could do just do size of
when I some people gonna complain their
way through you and thirties routine
right like that just what I should use
here all right and then that will give
you the actual count if you really want
to do it that way this will keep the
same and then I mean we probably need to
bind at some point if I run this right
now probably won't give us a triangle
cuz this is a bit suspicious and
unfortunately has been a while since
I've used up in jail but we will see
what we get here if anything okay so we
get nothing and we got a crash in fact
inside the driver
yeah probably nothing is found I mean
we're trying to draw element
yeah I bet we've got nothing to draw so
the other thing we need to do is
actually use our instead of just having
three hard-coded here we should get our
index buffer and actually get the count
that's why I wanted it here okay so
let's fix up our buffers cuz clearly I
am NOT as good as I thought
we need to bind our buffer which I guess
means that why do you use create why to
use Jen they're the same in terms of
buffers flecked textures you actually
specify the target immediately I kind of
maybe thought that it would be like the
same here
and but I guess not right so this is the
one with index buffer so you know open
gels a bit inconsistent even though it
tries to be consistent and the reason
they have create knowledge is to match
the shader API which has GL create
shaders you know Creator
um and Joe create program and by anyway
I guess we'll see so that's why you
should still use create instead of just
Jen because it that way your API is kind
of consistent or rather your queued like
OpenGL API is consistent let's run that
and see what happens and since we've
bounded and left it bound it should be
in the vertex all right now and
everything should be great and as you
can see it is
so hopefully that sheds some light as to
all the blabbing I did in the beginning
of the video where I was like you know
you have to do this you have to create
all these classes now we've done that
you can see we have the base classes
here which are just interfaces with no
data at all and then runtime we make the
choice to actually return a specific
instance of a specific rendering API I
hope you guys enjoy this video if you
did you can hit that like button you can
also help supply the series by going to
patreon come for slash the channel your
support is greatly appreciated and it is
what keeps his series going so huge
thank you to everyone who helps support
the series let me know what you think of
this kind of design let me know if
you've seen other designs that you think
of better this is the one that I've kind
of been using for years and to be honest
it's my favorite because all the
decisions are made at runtime and in
terms of performance like I don't know
some people out there might be
nitpicking being like but it's a virtual
dispatch every time you doesn't matter
like it honestly doesn't matter I've
done benchmarks around this kind of
stuff I have never been in this
situation where I've written a game or
an
and I've been like man you know I wish I
had the extra performance that having
non-virtual function calls would have
had I mean not saying that that scenario
doesn't exist I'm saying in my
experience and for what I'm doing and
for what I'm trying to do with hazel
which is gonna be a very high
performance like quite demanding and
visually you know visually demanding
kind of engine right
this kind of stuff definitely he's not
going to matter if you're making some
really small engine for like you know
pixel graphics I'm like an embedded
system yeah maybe this stuff would
matter but it doesn't for something like
this for homework see if you can create
you can create the shader API like of
this because right now I've just got
shader I've got the shade of glass but
it's actually just opengl functions
whereas this buffer does the movie file
has no relation to open jail at all
right we include opengl buffer but
that's again only if we're on the
platform that supports it and also you
know we're not including cloud or
anything like that and neither is opengl
buffer by the way if you look at opengl
if we just quickly look at the buffer
class this doesn't include GLAAD right
these CVP file does so we're never
actually including GLAAD into our
generic buffer class and we shouldn't
write same with kind of DirectX you
usually don't want to do that with rad
dice is probably okay
because you'll be only building that on
Windows but for something like this we
don't even need to and if you can avoid
it you definitely should and then the
other one you can have a go with is
vertex alright and just see if you can
make that application class completely
kind of generic anyway hope you guys
enjoy this very long episode been
sitting here for like an hour almost
next time I think we're gonna either
take more control with the renderer
class or I really want to also talk
about vertex arrays and how they fit in
and how we can abstract that and maybe
the buffer layout as well but yeah let
me know what you want to see and I'll
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]